y en ese hangar podría caber la Estatua de la Libertad,
para tener una idea del tamaño de ese Falcon Heavy Rocket.
CA: Y el hecho de que hay 27 motores allí.
Eso es parte del principio de diseño
que en lugar de inventar cohetes cada vez más grandes,
uno pueda unirlos.
GS: Es exactamente esta capacidad residual.
Desarrollamos el motor Merlin para el vehículo de lanzamiento Falcon 1.
Podríamos haber arrojado ese motor
y construir un motor completamente nuevo para el Falcon 9.
Se habría denominado algo diferente,
porque Falcon 9 es nueve motores Merlin,
pero en lugar de gastar USD 1000 millones en un nuevo motor,
ponemos nueve de ellos juntos en la parte trasera de Falcon 9.
Capacidad residual: pegue tres Falcon 9 juntos
y se obtiene el mayor cohete operacional volando.
Y fue costoso de hacer,
pero fue un camino mucho más eficiente que comenzar desde cero.
CA: Y el BFR es el equivalente a ¿cuánto más grande que eso,
en términos de su poder?
GS: BFR es aproximadamente, creo, dos veces y media más grande.
CA: Correcto, y eso te permite ...
Quiero decir, no me creo este video que estamos a punto de ver aquí.
¿Qué es esto?
GS: Actualmente está en la Tierra,
pero esto es básicamente un viaje espacial para los terrícolas.
No puedo esperar a esta capacidad residual.
Básicamente, lo que vamos a hacer es volar BFR como un avión
y hacer viajes punto a punto en la Tierra,
para que pueda despegar desde la ciudad de Nueva York o Vancouver
y volar a la mitad del globo.
Estarás en el BFR durante una media hora o 40 minutos,
y la parte más larga... sí, es tan increíble.
(Aplausos)
La parte más larga de ese vuelo es el bote hacia afuera y hacia atrás.
(Risas)
CA: Gwynne, vamos, esto es increíble, pero es una locura, ¿no?
Esto nunca va a suceder realmente.
GS: Oh sí, definitivamente va a suceder.
Esto definitivamente va a suceder.
CA: ¿Cómo?
(Aplausos)
En primer lugar, los países aceptarán este misil entrante...
(Risas)
GS: Chris, ¿te imaginas tratando de convencer a nivel federal,
bases de la Fuerza Aérea para aceptar los entrantes?
Porque lo estamos haciendo ya, regularmente.
Estamos trayendo las primeras etapas,
y aterrizamos en una propiedad federal, bases de la Fuerza Aérea.
Entonces creo que hacerlo, no sé,
a 10 km de una ciudad, tal vez solo esté a 5 km de una ciudad.
CA: ¿Cuántos pasajeros pueden permitirse la fortuna
de volar por el espacio?
GS: El primer BFR tendrá unos cien pasajeros.
Y hablemos un poco sobre el negocio.
Todos piensan que los cohetes son realmente caros,
y en gran medida lo son,
y ¿cómo podríamos competir con los boletos de avión aquí?
Pero si lo piensas bien, si puedo hacer este viaje
en media hora a una hora,
puedo hacer docenas de estos al día, ¿verdad?
Y un avión de largo recorrido solo puede hacer uno de esos vuelos al día.
Así que incluso si mi cohete fuera un poco más caro
y el combustible es un poco más caro,
puedo ejecutar 10 veces lo que están ejecutando en un día,
y realmente hacer que los ingresos que necesito salgan de ese sistema.
CA: Realmente crees que esto se implementará en algún momento
en nuestro increíble futuro ¿Cuándo?
GS: Dentro de una década, seguro.
CA: ¿Y este es tiempo Gwynne o tiempo Elon?
CA: Es tiempo Gwynne. Estoy segura de que Elon querrá que vayamos más rápido.
(Risas)
CA: Eso es ciertamente sorprendente.
GS: Personalmente he invertido en esto, porque viajo mucho
y no me gusta viajar,
y me encantaría ver a mis clientes en Riyadh,
salir por la mañana y regresar a tiempo para preparar la cena.
CA: Entonces vamos a probar esto.
Dentro de 10 años, el precio de un boleto de segunda por persona
será de un par de miles de dólares para volar de Nueva York a Shanghái.
GS: Sí, creo que será boleto de segunda y primera,
pero se hará en una hora.
CA: Sí, bueno, está bien, definitivamente es algo.
(Risas)
Y mientras tanto, el otro uso de BFR que se está desarrollando
es ir un poco más allá que Shanghái.
Habla de esto.
Uds. han desarrollado algo bastante detallado, una especie de imagen
de cómo los humanos podrían volar a Marte,
y cómo se vería eso.
GS: Sí. Tenemos un video, este es un video recortado
de otros que hemos mostrado, y hay un par de cosas nuevas.
Pero, básicamente, se despega de una plataforma,
con un cohete, así como BFS, la nave espacial Big Falcon.
Va a despegar.
El cohete va a dejar la nave espacial en órbita
órbita terrestre baja,
y luego regresa al igual que devolvemos los cohetes en este momento.
Suena increíble, pero estamos trabajando en las piezas,
y puedes vernos lograr estas piezas.
Así que el cohete vuelve.
Lo nuevo aquí
es que aterrizaremos en la plataforma desde la que la lanzamos.
Actualmente aterrizamos en una plataforma separada o en un bote.
Conexión rápida y veloz.
Tomas un buque de carga lleno de combustible,
o un depósito de combustible,
se pone en el cohete, se pone en órbita,
hace una maniobra de atraque, reposta la nave espacial,
y se dirige a su destino,
y este es Marte.
CA: Entonces, cien personas van a Marte al mismo tiempo,
y lleva qué, ¿seis meses? ¿Dos meses?
GS: Termina dependiendo de lo grande que sea el cohete.
Creo que esta primera versión, y seguiremos haciendo
incluso mayores que el BFR.
Creo que es un viaje de tres meses.
En este momento, el promedio es de seis a ocho,
pero vamos a tratar de hacerlo más rápido.
CA: ¿Cuándo crees que SpaceX aterrizará al primer humano en Marte?
GS: Es un marco de tiempo muy similar al punto a punto.
Es la misma capacidad.
Será en una década, no en esta década.
CA: En tiempo real, nuevamente, dentro de una década.
Eso también sería increíble.
(Risas)
¿Pero por qué? ¿En serio, por qué?
Quiero decir, existe esa empresa con esa la misión oficial declarada.
¿Han comprado todos esa misión
dado que, hay mucha gente
que piensa, tienen mucho talento,
y mucha capacidad tecnológica.
Y hay muchas cosas en la Tierra que necesitan atención urgente.
¿Por qué tienen ese viaje de escape a otro planeta en mente?
(Aplausos)
GS: Me alegra que me hayas preguntado eso,
pero creo que tenemos que expandir nuestras mentes un poco.
Hay muchas cosas que hacer en la Tierra,
pero hay muchas compañías trabajando en eso.
Creo que trabajamos en una de las cosas más importantes que podemos,
y eso es encontrar otro lugar para que los humanos vivan, sobrevivan y prosperen.
Si algo sucediera en la Tierra,
los humanos deben vivir en otro lado.
(Aplausos)
Es la reducción de riesgo fundamental para la especie humana.
Y esto no subvierte
hacer que nuestro planeta aquí sea mejor y hacer un mejor trabajo para cuidarlo,
pero creo que se necesitan múltiples caminos para sobrevivir,
Y este es uno de ellos.
Y no hablemos de la pieza deprimente,
como, vas a Marte para asegurarte de que todos los terrícolas no mueran.
Eso es terrible, de hecho, esa es una razón terrible para hacerlo.
Fundamentalmente, es otro lugar para explorar,
y eso es lo que hace a los humanos diferentes de los animales,
es nuestro sentido de exploración y sentido de asombro
y aprender algo nuevo.
Y luego también tengo que decir,
este es el primer paso moviéndonos a otros sistemas solares
y potencialmente otras galaxias,
y creo que esta es la única vez que sobrepaso la visión de Elon,
porque quiero conocer otras personas en otros sistemas solares.
Marte está bien, pero necesita arreglo.
Hay trabajo que hacer allí para hacerlo habitable.
(Risas)
Quiero encontrar personas o como se llamen,
en otro sistema solar.
CA: Esa es una gran visión.
Gwynne Shotwell, gracias.
Tienes uno de los trabajos más increíbles del planeta.
GS: Muchas gracias. Gracias, Chris.